when Alex did a video on linked list
there's a lot of comments on it it sort
of thing I want to use a linked list
arrays a factor what's the point of
reading this and so I was sort of
thinking about is that well actually uh
I raise faster than the linked list or
in the linked list after an array how do
we go about finding out which one's
faster so let's have a shoot out arrays
which is linked list
I should just remind ourselves what the
difference is between a linked list and
an array so let's start with the array
so probably the simplest to understand
an array is just a way of storing
several values in memory so we start off
with the first value and for the
purposes of this demonstration I'm going
to use a structure containing multiple
values we did talk about objects a while
ago structures of what you had before we
saw this object which is a collection of
values in memories and store to integer
values so this is array element zero and
it's got two numbers we then got array
element one and it's got three numbers
looks like I'm playing break out got a
great element to and it's got two
numbers and so we can refer to any of
these by reference to the index starts
at 0 3 4 5 6 7 10 so you can have an
array of any size we have to know how
big it is if you wanted to be when you
create so you allocate the memory for
all the things and then you can store
some values so we can write 42 in this
one we can put 21 in here I'm going to
put 3 in that one and we can store them
or we can put different values in here
as well as we need them so that's how an
array works which is one big block of
memory each thing stored one after the
other linked list works slightly
different we start off at the beginning
of the linked list and it points at
nothing but then as we add things to the
list we allocate the memory for it we're
going to store two things so the first
thing we'll label these things inside it
P and Q so it's a lot P here and we've
got Q but we also have an extra thing
that tells us where the next they will
be and that's empty too so it's all put
42 and 16 so we just allocate space for
that one structure that one thing that
we're going to store and we connect it
up so we point this at the first thing
so we often call this something like
first and we see Alex videos to see how
that have done so when we want to store
the next thing we allocate explai for
another one and we can store the value
so we've still got 8 21 in it
now the difference between this could be
anywhere else in memory and we connect
to the next pointer to point in to the
next thing so we have some known
starting point which points to the first
thing and the first thing 22 the second
thing and the second thing would point
to the third thing and so on and that
would point down and these could be all
over anywhere in the computer's memory
and then at the end you normally point
it at some known value which is often
referred to as null and is often the
number zero so you can then walk through
your list and when you find at the next
point of zero or null you know you've
come to the end of it there are two
different ways of storing data the best
or the same amount of data now he's got
some differences this one as I says it's
fixed inside and you create it you can
store how many things you know I've
actually filled in but as soon as you
get more than eleven since final top
array you can't go past eleven if you
can see yeah the numbers all go to 11 on
this however if we wanted to put
something else thing we can just get rid
of this thing and update this to point
to a new thing so we can make this grow
quite easily and we can also be really
clever we can add things in the middle
and the beginning very very simply but
we're going to go into that today
so creating them we're probably only
going to do once but which one is
actually faster well let's think about
what actually to do let's define a very
very simple problem we've created the
structure here and it's got two things
in it it's got an integer called P and
an integer called Q so saving the linked
list and in the array let's consider an
operation where we're just going to go
through all the elements in our array or
all the elements in our linked list and
sum the value of P are going to add up
all the value so we're going to add up
what's in array element zeroes P in
array of them at once P and so on so
we're going to effectively do
something's going to add them all up
we'll do the same with the linked list
as well so we're going to set what the
first thing is to point to P now that
one no there's no time out of its value
of P the next one and so on and we'll
add them all up
why are we using missiles they want to
the unique thing about this is that it's
going to visit every single element in
either the array or every single element
in the linked list so we're going to
visit every single element if you only
have to visit one element then the very
nature of random access into array means
as we fast there's no way you can make
any difference unless it's the first
element if you only one to ever access
the first element then look at the same
speed we fuel directly to random element
then the array or win hands down you can
just think about how it works that will
be the case we're going to consider we
want to access every single element and
do something to it and in this case
you're just going to sum up the values
but it could be if things were
representing say windows on the screen
we want to move them around we want to
redraw them whatever it is will then do
something to every single wall so we
sort of set out the problem I'm going to
go over an array of values and a linked
list of values I'm going to in sum in
the visits all and we do actually add up
all the numbers stored in the element P
which is part of the structure so what
I've done is I've written to see poems
which are more or less identical I'm
going to create 125,000 elements in my
array or mailing list and in the linked
list I've got a structure which contains
an integer P and an integer Q and in the
array version I've got a structure which
contains an integer P and interested Q
in the array item the only difference is
that the linked list has one extra item
which is the next pointer to the next
thing so very listen see so hopefully
we'll go as fast as we possibly can
most of the rest of the program is
identical so I have my main routine here
which creates a list or an array of
random number generator 125,000 random
numbers which is a slowest part of the
program you'll see and then store them
so allocate memory for each element in
the linked list and then we set the
value everything else will just leave
with 0 and we do the same with the array
just as we did on the paper we then run
the program 100 times and all going to
here is time how long it takes to run a
function which adds afforda numbers
either in the list or in the array
I will do that 100 times and then we can
work out the average time it takes to
calculate one and we'll print out the
values as we go so we're just using the
built-in clock function in C which
should be accurate accurate enough for
what we want to do so the real meat the
body of the program is this function
here some list or some array let's start
with the array one because possibly the
simplest we said a variable to be zero
that's going to be asked some you have
another variable I which is going to be
our index through the array and we go
from I equals zero
I first element until we get to the end
the number of elements in there and we
just say this sum equals the value that
was already in sum plus the value in the
ice element in the array a P element
remember we said the array had a P and a
Q in it we want the value stored in the
P space within the structure in our
array so I'm just going to add get them
together the list version very very
similar
we set the someone to be 0 we say while
p does not equal null so why we haven't
reached the end of the list and we set P
initially to be the first thing in the
linked list so pointing out that first
thing sum equals sum plus P inside P we
using P inside P confusing variable
names but then I'm asleep programmer and
then we set P IR pointer to point to the
next thing so we follow the link to the
next thing in the linked list and we
keep doing that until we come to the end
there are two programs as simple as you
get in terms of implementing a linked
list or on array so we're going to do is
run them and we should get some values
output but we're not going to run them
on the I max we're not going to run them
on the Raspberry Pi we're actually going
to run them on the Atari behind me which
means I need a very high peak high-tech
piece of equipment so I need a floppy
disk to transfer other programs from the
iMac go topping them off the iMac and
then we can run them on the Atari so go
over to the Atari and assurance that
it's cameras and spot we can see it so
what I'm gonna do at first is they got
to run the list first also going to
generate 125,000 linked list values to
let it run
right while it loads off the floppy disk
that's what it used to be like back in
the 80s and 90s you had to wait one you
crave them ran a while a long while and
this is just a simple program so there
is good so it's not initializing the
link list it's allocating all the memory
for the different elements and then
putting a random number in the p value
of each one so we'll let that run in the
words of the old hobbit computer game
time passes or in the words of every
Apple of this secret short how long does
this take a while lots of oil I don't
know another time this bit 125,000 times
however long it takes to allocate a
random number and allocate some memory
on the clock speed of what this is
actually an 8 megahertz CPU so it's a
takes a while the computer loaded off
all the code for the program and off the
floppy disk into memory and it's now
running it to generate the data set that
we need then gonna sum all the values so
everything is happening now will happen
off memory it's just taking a while to
process it but we are recording it in 4k
which is a slight overkill I hope you're
getting into that extra bit so the
programs going through now and we'll let
it run 400 times we'll get an average
but actually looking at the values of
the coming up I think we can safely
assume that the average is going to end
up being 166 clock ticks now when I say
QWOP takes each of the machines we're
going to look at are going to have
different clocks perms that they use the
time things so we can't compare the
values directly what we could come read
with the seconds but we can certainly
see the relative patterns between it
will call that 166 clock ticks over to
run the linked list version of the
program it takes 166 clock ticks
so let's now run the array version of
the program so now we're going to do
exactly the same thing we're going to
allocate an array every time
twenty-five thousand elements and
populate them with random values because
of the way I've written the program it
will actually be the same pseudo random
number sequence that the sum should be
the same and then we're going to fill
each of them up and time how long that
takes and we'll they'll see whether an
array actually is faster than the linked
list or whether a linked list will be B
array so that to me looks like that
little spinny thing is going faster yeah
well so and I haven't just upgraded the
processor while they're off camera
what's actually happening is when we
allocate the space for the linked list
we have to allocate space for each
element and then for the gym there we
allocate space for the next element we
could do that in a different way and
speed things up but we did it that's the
classic way with the array we allocate
the whole lot in one go so we all take
one huge block of memory under 25,000
times eight is about one Meg's worth of
memory so allocate all that in one go
and then we're just going through it
filling in all the values setting all
the values so that should be quicker and
it seems and spinning wheel is going
slightly faster what why would that spin
wheel very fast can you just learn how
that you can read it if you've heard
this thing you it yeah so to give some
nice sort of visual feedback while this
is running well I'm just a plain white
screen what I'm doing is I'm printing
every hundred element ideals I update
that thing and just printing either a
dash a vertical line or one of the two
slashes to make it look like it's
getting round and those are printing it
it creates a little effect which is see
that something's happened and the
computer hasn't crashed so this should
be faster and we should get a value so
is now working and the immediate thing
we see is that the array is taking about
179 or 178 ticks it's the same quad kick
so we can compare these two values the
array is slower than a linked list I
know down okay all right now so you
can't argue in - okay so the numbers
have come in the computers around 170
angular call is to that 170 8.5 always
for the final average to come in but for
that so they're roughly comparable
basically there's not much
it sort of thing but there's something
about 200 QWOP ticks per second on this
machine it's is probably a noticeable
it's about 10 percent slower okay so
that's it I mean we can stop here come a
that's it we know what's what arrays are
slow you wrinkly yep so arrays are
slower than Ling Li gotta get my vendor
video yeah and a video you can now bring
up the slash computer so virtually there
are two ways you can walk over the Ray
we went up the array from the smaller
numbers to the larger numbers but we
could also start at the larger indexes
and move back to the smaller indexes and
I thought well let's try it both ways
let's not have anyone posting some
comments saying no but if you went the
other way
so let's run it the other way so I wrote
a version which walks down and because
we're adding the numbers together we'll
get exactly the same answer a plus B
equals B plus a and all that you can
watch numberphile to find out more
online I'm sure you think this would
take exactly the same amount of time so
just update our table to do this and
we're going to have the reverse array
here I'll just wait while it does that
so going backwards through the array the
only thing can we do the same thing with
the linked list
well the way we've designed the linked
list we have a pointer to the next thing
in each thing but we don't have a
pointer back to the previous thing it's
a singly linked list so we can only move
forwards along it we could design it to
be a doubly linked list and have a
backwards and forwards pointer but if
you think about it if we started at the
end and move backwards that's going to
be exactly the same operations as if we
start at the beginning and before so
there's actually no point in testing
it'd be exactly the same code we just be
using different offsets into memory so
taking exactly the same amount of time
while we wait for that to do its thing
let's run the same programs on the iMac
and see how much faster it is so let's
compile them up I am turning on as I did
before all the optimizations for the
array and things that'll make it go as
fast as poss
but some of the comparison to the array
test and I going to compile with the
speed test done and I'm going to do the
same thing for the link test I'm going
to say something really obvious now but
it's honestly a heck of a lot quicker
this machine just to get compiled up and
ready yeah those machines much faster
because while I'm compiling everything
on here and then transferring it across
rather than trying to get my old C
compiler going on the Atari and also the
chances are this will produce better
code so it'll take make the most benefit
of the speed we can pile them up so
let's run the linked list test as we did
before boom it's done everything now you
notice that took a lot quicker the
numbers are still roughly in the same
order still about 100 and around 200 but
remember this is a different clock we
cannot compare the ticks from that one -
it's on the different numbers but we get
the average here two hundred and nine
point five four I'm acting this is 166
Atari ticks they're much slower chicks
than the I like ticks we can't compare
that to that we can compare horizontally
let's do the same now with the array
test and Wow
when we did the linked list test on the
Atari it was faster than the array test
roughly take you about ten percent
faster nothing really in it you could
say look at the difference on the iMac
the iMac takes forty three point four
four clock ticks to do the array 209
that's five times faster for the array
was on the Atari the linked list was
faster so a reverse array is now going
on the Atari 114 and that's quicker
that's quicker than the original array
and that's quicker than the linked list
so if we do everything backwards doogie
where it's very good if you do
everything forwards
it's much slower I'm a bit confused is
there any possibility that's just a
problem the code or something always are
you going to reveal something to this
year we need to delve a bit deeper here
to see what's really going on
remember we wrote these programs in C so
we wrote these in the high-level
language and then they got compiled down
to the instructions that the machine can
execute and what's actually happening
here is that the research shows that the
machine can execute favor walking
backwards down something compared with
going further upwards now let's run that
same array backwards program on the iMac
for completing this so let me compile
that one up and again I'm optimizing
everything to the hilt test and so we'll
run speed tests back and we'll run this
one so before the arrays now much faster
according to this a reversal rate should
be faster than the forward array so what
would you expect the value to be shown
for run on the reverse away about
fifteen or twenty directly if it was the
same as that did all right
would you like to stick with that answer
or would you like to change that Oh
nervous excited actually because the
Atari was faster to do a linked list in
an array and the iMac was the other way
around I'm going to say it's going to be
slower to do it in reverse so you reckon
firm supposed to do it in reverse
oh I do like an indecisive person there
we go average time forty seven point
four six
so marginally slow marginally slower
about 10% slower but still an order of
magnitude faster than this we could do
the same on the Raspberry Pi so again
we'll compile all of these up so we'll
do it array test compile it up
noticeably slower to compile will do the
ll test this is the list version
and we'll do the reverse test so compile
them all up on the last repair so let's
run these and get the numbers we've run
the array test we now get nine 165 point
seven five as an average for the array
will run the link list and we get one
eight five eight point six one for the
linked list test and now we run the
reverse test and we get 101 9.5 five so
we've run the test now so we've we've
assumed nothing we've ran some tests or
to get some data so we can see which is
faster an array or liquids with this
operation we've been trying and we've
got some pretty interesting results so
we're running on the Atari the linked
list was faster than the array unless he
ran the array backwards in which case
the array was faster than the linked
list and the array going forward we'll
come back to that we ran it on the
raspberry pi and here the array was
about twice as fast as the linked list
baby rarely backwards the array was
slower and if you do it on the iMac view
range height I'm faster than the linked
list
whichever way you went so what's going
on here well let's ignore the imac for
the minute the apple haters will love
that bit but let's ignore the imac for
though and let's just have a look at the
raspberry pi and the Attali so we've got
the Atari and the Raspberry Pi and we'll
just go with the array speed and the
link to this so we've got about one
hundred and seventy nine for that and
one hundred and sixty-six clock ticks
that now when we can't compare the clock
ticks between the different machines
because they're different different
clocks used in the machines but we can
compare them relatively between the same
thing on the same machine for the
Raspberry Pi
it was 966 and that was a 1859 Kish now
what's going on here well the thing we
need to remember if you look at the
machine code it's roughly the same
length the same number of operation now
on the Atari some of the instructions
will take slightly longer than
to execute but that's not what gets
going on here we need to think back to
the video on cashiers that we did the
difference between the Raspberry Pi CPU
would have been much faster and more
modern and the Ataris is that the Ataris
doesn't have a cache so every
instructionally needs to fetch every bit
of data that needs to fetch has to be
fetched from memory each time no it's
not cached broadly speaking we believe
something going on there but broadly
speaking with no cache is about half the
prefetch buffer if you want to get into
the details but we can see there's no
cash so if we think about the CPU in the
Atari then it's having to access memory
for everything so everything that the
CPU needs to fetch on the Atari the
instructions the data from the array or
a linked list and of course the next
pointer from the linked list has to come
from memory so it takes the same amount
of time we get are the two weather
fetching data or fetching instructions
on the Raspberry Pi however we still got
the main body the CPU which is going to
execute things and it has memory as well
but in between there we have a cache in
fact we actually probably have two
caches one for data and one for
instructions as I want to see if you
activate as we looked at in the previous
video is access to it via the caches and
then they if they haven't got it to get
it from memory so why does this make a
difference surely things will still wake
up so well on the Atari the fastest
thing in the theory is basically the
memory the memory is much faster than
the CPU that's about twice as fast
and so the memory can provide a data
exactly when the CPU needs it there's no
real need for cash
move ahead to the Raspberry Pi and the
are make of course then the CPU is much
faster than the memory so when CPU ask
for something it has to wait while the
memory provides it now let's figure out
how what happens when we run our program
with the array
on the Raspberry Pi every instruction
after the first time will be accessed
will be cached in the instruction cache
so the first time we go through the loop
all the instructions are going to be
used in that loop will have been cached
in the instruction cap so you can get
these immediately the data particularly
with the array would also collapse a bit
with a linked list we don't get just one
or two bytes in each time I'll get what
we call a cache line pickups 128 bytes
in a go so we'll get some of the data
that we already need into the cache as
well so some of the data will already be
there in the array more so with your
right so the reason of the array runs
faster on the Raspberry Pi is that all
the instructions are coming straight out
of the Institute basically giving us a
fast lane for those instructions so they
get there immediately there's only the
data that needs to get from main memory
which will get cached as well
so the same happens with the route list
program except for one crucial
difference with the linked list poem we
have to make one memory access to get
the data value that we're going to sum
and then we have to make another memory
access which has to go through the cat
into main memory for the address of the
next thing we have to make to memory
request which may get satisfied by main
memory here where's our the array one we
only have to make one for the value that
we're interested in and because of the
cache we get sort of a fast passing
instructions and so actually not having
to do that second memory access to get
the next pointer here means that this
the ArrayList of the program ends are
working about twice as fast on the Atari
because everything is coming from memory
it doesn't matter whether you're reading
an instruction or reading a bit of data
it's still going to come from memory
each time so actually the front of the
value is already pre-calculated
in memory means that actually runs
slightly faster I mean we're talking
perhaps 10% faster not really a billion
so we get a slight speed benefit now to
show that this is the case I took the
same version of the program on the Atari
and ran it on the Atari router now the
difference for the Atari ST we use there
and the Falcon is that the Falcon has a
slightly later version of the 68000
processor which has a cache
in it both instructions and data cache
and when I ran that on there the times
that came out so the array was 46 clock
ticks is much faster processor anyway
and the link list was 58.5 clock ticks
so on the Falcon because you've got the
cache they're just like on the Raspberry
Pi the array version ends up being
traffic exactly the same program exactly
the same machine code because you've got
the cache there the array version ends
up being faster because the instructions
of their professional and that sort of
fat packs from the cache rather having
to go to main memory each time mean that
the irradiation becomes faster than the
linked list version now tell them other
things we haven't talked about yet
why is the reverse array faster on the
Atari simple answer to that it just uses
slightly different instructions their
instructions on the six 8000 that allow
you to do a decrement testing with zero
branch which isn't all in one
instruction so you can actually make the
code slightly more compact and run
slightly faster again it's a small
enough time why then is the iMac
significantly faster we're getting sort
of five times faster well that's because
I use a slightly different compiler that
I use the clang C compiler on the iMac
rather than GCC for the other two and it
cheats it it squats that you've got an
array axises in the loop and it says
well okay rather than doing a loop
around one array access I will do a loop
around eight array accesses all in one
go so it actually removes some of the
tests for the loop and it makes the
program much faster for the compilers
being clever and optimizing the program
so it runs faster the answer to whether
the raise faster than the link list or
not very much depends on how you CPU in
the machine that you've built is
configured to actually execute the code
so you can't make assumptions about how
a CPU will execute code you really need
to do the test to see what's happening
even within the same architecture family
the difference between the six 8006 8030
in the falcon mean that assumptions we
make based on what they
charity did where the rally was slower
than the link list aren't true on the
Falcon and when you move it on to a
completely different architecture like
the Raspberry Pi or the x86 chip in the
iMac then again you get different
effects so the best thing is when you're
faced with a question question like this
and you're not sure come up with some
test and collect real data and you'll be
able to see what's going on
[Music]
could you